Okay. Should be live here. Hi guys. I've
had all sorts of lovely issues to deal
with this morning.
Um, and I have a bunch of meetings later
today. So, I'm not going to be able to
get as much streaming in as I'd like,
but I figure I'm going to do a quick
1hour one now and then we're going to do
an afternoon/eing session as well.
Let me check if the stream has audio
because I've had all mic issues.
Looks like we're good.
Yeah, that seems like we're good.
Okay.
Um,
let me pull this up in the background
and I'll switch the stream view over.
I'm going to grab a drink and I think
we're going to just do one hour of solid
refactors on this thing to get started
at the moment. That's the plan. Let me
get my coffee.
was that we were going to try to get
like a point array thing going. Hello,
welcome. Um, let me think about how we
do this. So, right now we have we
basically have a double nested dict or a
double nested array. It's not keybased.
Doing well, thanks. Well, enough. I kind
of gotten delayed by a bunch of things
today. I was hoping to have gotten a few
hours of dev in already, but I'll make
up for it today and this evening. Um,
what I'd like to do is I'd like to have
a flat data structure for this, I think.
Right.
Yeah, cuz I basically what I want to do
here, right, is I want to just have like
one big data strct.
Hey, Jess.
Oh, but then it's like, hang on, they're
kind of two different things, right?
So, what we want is
we want to be able to plot everything.
And as we're plotting each point on this
screen,
Yeah. as we're plotting each point on
the screen, we want to be able to
record it.
Okay,
that's a little different from what I
was expecting actually. Let me just go
through the logic and see if there's
anything else that we need to change
fundamentally.
This stuff is just like basic code
optimization refactors, right? The axis
thing is annoying, but we'll figure it
out.
uh box plot not a big deal from there.
The GL stuff is fine. The particle stuff
here
So then the only thing to figure out I
suppose is how it hooks into the drop
downs.
Oh, and also the other um
there's one more check.
So this thing iterates through
all ends.
Is it easier to have this in flat form?
I don't even think it necessarily is
easier to have this in flatform, right?
It just adds like endex tracking
annoyance.
And then same for these, right? Yeah.
Alien.
So
Oh, yeah. I guess there's no more
deadlifts today. I have the title wrong,
but whatever.
Uh,
I'm trying to figure out what's like the
most convenient way to do drop downs,
right?
cuz I actually I need the index in the
original
I know. This is what happens when I like
crowd my head with like administrative
stuff in the morning. Like I'm not in
the right mind frame to think about this
properly.
I feel like this is not as hard as I as
I'm making it out to be.
and there's no way around it either. I
need this feature.
I kill two birds at once.
Let me see.
What other stuff don't I like? I don't
like the key lookup.
But the reason I have the key lookup is
because
that can honestly more be handled from
Python, right?
Like we only need to log
specific keys.
So yeah, that can be handled from
Python. End
names and hypers
did transfer to pop. Had issues with
config. It tried. It's still having
errors with batch sizes.
Batch sizes.
What do you mean with batch sizes? What
error are you getting?
Are you getting an internal error or a
usage like an API usage error?
Just post the error you're getting or
like link the config or whatever.
Okay. So, I can technically Yeah, I can
fix it. So you don't need fixed hyper
pram keys. Um but that actually is not
like a huge help right on its own. Yeah,
that does not help a ton on its own.
And that doesn't change the schema.
The thing I basically would need would
be um
it would change it to be the other
format, right? So it's like
uh what is it? Dict of arrays instead of
array of dicts or the other thing. But I
like the current format's actually
better for almost all plotting.
So,
what I need is I need um
Well, actually, how much is how much
does it change?
that still doesn't help me,
does it?
I guess it mildly helps.
No, because then we still have the
environment key problem. Okay, so that
doesn't help me at all.
Going on the hunt.
Refactoring code. Way simpler.
The thing I'm trying to figure out is
how we get an index.
how we get an index from um
the points
or basically how if we're going to
record which points are where on the
screen basically just recording pixel
positions I also need to know
I need to be able to like link to them
somehow and it's very hard the way I
have that.
We'll just do Nvid.
It's better to get something done than
nothing. Let's just get NID
and um
index like for now
and that should be enough.
we're going to just crank for the next
40 minutes or so, and I'm going to see
if I can get something done.
that's not how it works. FF XF. Um, so
if you run your environment
and you get the little dashboard and you
look at the percentages, if your NV is
at a very low percent, then you're not
going to get anything more out of your
CPU, your GPU bottlenecked. If your NV
is at a high percent, then your CPU
bottlenecked.
So like typically you want to have a
reasonable batch size first of all. It's
not just about using all hardware. It's
like the batches have to be good for the
hardware. So, typically look at our
default batch sizes and stuff for that.
Um,
then you're going to have the number of
workers used. You don't need to use all
your cores if um you're already like
saturating with fewer cores. Like you
very rarely should need all the cores
cuz our M's the M's are so fast that
like you don't need that like you don't
need that many cores. There's zero to be
gained after a certain point. Um,
if you just link me your config XF, just
like link me the config on GitHub or
whatever, I'll look at it
or pastin if you just want to give me
the one file, whatever.
Damn it. You literally don't even know
the uh
end of index on these, do you?
How do you go about translating business
requirements into technical requirements
for clients? We set up a scoping deal.
Typically, we charge we take anywhere
from 2 to four weeks um to go through
the specifications that a client has and
turn it into an MSPEC and then go back
and forth and make sure that they're
happy that this satisfies what they want
and that it's something that we can
actually build.
You have to prove how it's going to
generate value. Well, yeah. Well, no,
actually. Well, yes and no. Right. So,
we don't sell clients on like, hey, you
should hire us to do this project for
the most part, right? We kind of do our
thing and then people come to us because
they have projects in mind and then the
scoping process is not like us trying to
sell you on what we should build. It's
like you want this thing built. Okay,
let's work together to figure out what
the implementation of this would
actually look like in a way that
satisfies all your concerns and is
something that we can also build.
We don't really do like the
non-technical sales side, right?
Like we build sims. We build higher sims
for integration with RL. If you want one
of those, we build it.
We don't go out and say this is why you
should hire us to build you a technical
Hyperf SIM for RL
because I'm not a businessman first and
foremost, right? Like I don't want to
spend my time doing that. I want to
spend my time doing awesome research and
advancing the science.
Um, it depends on what your objective
is, Spirit. So if your goal is like how
do I build a company as fast as possible
then and like expand that as much as
possible, sure. My goal is more like how
do I have a profitable pro I a
profitable private lab that advances
science and does well enough. Right? So,
like if I lose some fraction of clients
because I'm not doing enough on that
side, that's fine with me as long as,
you know, it's still profitable. It's
still growing at some reasonable pace
and we're crushing the science side.
Where do models get saved after
training? Do this.
Cuz so spirit basically like the way the
reason I think like this is that I like
with the stuff I'm building I'm
confident it's going to be successful
either way. So like there's some big
number. I guess the way that I look at
like my work is there's some big number
that you can give me where it's like
cool, I'm personally I'm set with
everything that I want to do for myself
and then there's some number that's like
10x that or whatever where anything over
that amount I'm just going to put back
into doing cool science anyways.
And I'm pretty sure that I can get the
first number on my own doing whatever.
So why wouldn't instead of like spending
a bunch of years of my life trying to
make a bunch of money to then do
science, why wouldn't I just do the
science now, right?
I guess it comes like there's this
concept of like the delayed life plan
where it's like I'm going to go make a
bunch of money and then go do what I
want with it. Well, if I can do what I
want right now, I'm just going to do
that.
Oh, it absolutely will still burn you
out, spirit. Hard work is hard work. I
don't do this stuff constantly. I need
breaks, right? I need sometimes long
breaks. But then you see me here
sometimes where it's like, yeah, I'm
just going to code for 12 hours a day,
every day, this whole week. No biggie,
sometimes more. But I don't do that
always. And when I need a break, like I
don't work on this stuff when I don't
feel like I can make progress. There's
no point in staring at your screen and
getting nothing done.
Just me home. Just been learning stuff.
I need to get my [ __ ] together. So
that's the other thing about
programming. I think programming burns
you out way more than like let's say
you're doing robotics like not like
software side robotics. Let's say you're
working with physical hardware. Having a
physical component to what you're doing
makes it way easier to pull long hours.
Programming is like all mental. Like
typing on a keyboard does not count as
physical engagement. It's very very much
a thing where it's like when my mind is
slipping and I can't focus. Even if I'm
like streaming and like having like a
chat engagement, even if I've got music
on, when I get to that point, it's like,
okay, maybe I needed a day off, maybe I
need a week off, whatever it takes for
me to get back productive. It's way
better for me to just take the time and
then come back productive because
otherwise I'm not going to get anything
done. I'm going to make myself miserable
cuz I'm not getting anything done and
I'm just wasting my time, right?
So, I'm very much an advocate of like
you should work hard and you should want
to work hard, but you shouldn't force
yourself to work when you cannot be
productive. When you've done everything
that you possibly can in order to be
productive
spirit, learn by building.
Go learn stuff by building stuff.
Do projects.
Do small like do projects you can
actually finish that will teach you
something.
That's how you learn.
Okay, this is not
It's pretty close.
Don't do [ __ ] to make yourself
miserable. Like, it's like a such a hard
thing to do. And no matter what, like
when you're building stuff, they're
always going to be hard portions.
But as much as you possibly can.
Like building stuff is awesome.
It should feel that way most of the
time.
I have a couple guides on Twitter if you
haven't read them already.
They have a lot of my best advice.
If you want to do RL specifically, just
go through my tutorial because my
tutorial it's like it has some reading
but it's broken up by build this
project. Now build this next project,
right? And it doesn't give you starter
code or anything. It's just like go
figure out how to do it.
I was too stubborn. Yeah. So, I am very
stubborn as well, which is the way uh
the re like which is the reason I tell
people stuff so bluntly because
otherwise people don't listen. Those
guides have my best advice. Read them
and [ __ ] follow them. At least like
give them a full genuine try and if
something doesn't work for you, come
here and tell me. All right? Instead of
just not doing it, come here and tell me
and ask me [ __ ]
This whole dashboard that I've built
here, this is like freaking undergrad
level C. This is like not complicated
[ __ ] Even though this is awesome. Okay,
the shaders are a bit of a pain, but
everything else is like really basic
[ __ ] and you can make awesome things.
So just the thing is it's kind of both
at the same time. I am incredibly
stubborn to the point that I've
basically like even when I have in
retrospect had some really good mentors.
I really wasn't able to learn from them
fully because basically in order for me
to learn from somebody they have to blow
me out of the water so badly that it's
just like completely obvious that I
would be stupid to do anything but
listen to them, right? It has to be
overwhelming. And as a result, I spend a
lot of time blundering through like dumb
[ __ ] that I could have learned faster,
but at the same time, like I have a lot
of drive to just do things. And
sometimes I end up being right, you
know? And when I am right and everyone
else is wrong, well, that's when you
make something that's really crazy and
out there, right? That's like, hey, RL
is now just super fast. Hey, did you
know building M is easy, right?
I could really easily add this to
everything else, right?
I only need to add it to two more
things.
That doesn't even make a terrible,
terrible mess of the code. That's
something I can refactor my way out of.
Could this run? Wait, could this run in
wasim
How can I tune my hyperparameters with
protein? Is there any tutorial?
Literally just puffer sweep. Or if you
want the the uh non um the non- entry
point version,
And then you can do like d- Neptune or
D-Wanb
tag my tag name, you know, it's on the
uh the cheat sheet.
It's on the cheat sheet.
Could I view this in a web browser
instead of Yes, Peru, you can view this
in a web browser. We don't need tail
scale is I mean tail scale is like a
totally different thing.
But yeah, this is going to just go on
our browser and I might even make it so
you can drop a file into it.
Oh, I see. Um
there might be a way we can do that as
well. That might be a little harder
though. For real,
if you want to help me figure that out,
that'd be awesome.
Use tail scale to view. What do you mean
use to view remotely? We use tail scale
just for like SSH management
for puffer.
You're using it for something else.
Oh, okay. I see.
If you want to show me like a good way
to do that. I don't I don't like really
like the idea of having to do tail scale
for it. I think it would be way cooler
if we could just like could we like port
forward and load the file into it or
something? I don't know.
Bro just wants to say read the docs.
Well, I mean the docs are not the type
of docs you like. It's Rayb style docs,
right? It's a cheat sheet. So, I'm not
going to say oh yeah, the docs are super
complete.
But the trade-off here is that Puffer as
a project like the source is way simpler
than you'd expect. If you literally just
open the file and start playing with it.
I put a lot of work in trying to keep
puffer as simple as possible. It's going
to get simpler over time, not more
complex as well.
Can open a local port. Uh Peru, you're
going to have to be able to load like a
binary file into the program though from
the remote machine. I don't know how to
do that.
Can you like remote load a little file?
It's like a couple megs
expose while some HTML. If you have an
idea how to do that, then sure. The only
way I've I compiled these to wasome to
stick them on the website, but that's
different because you still have to get
the file from your viewer.
I mean, the other thing you can do is
just SCP the file over and drop it into
your browser, right?
But that's kind of clunky.
That might be the simplest. I don't
know.
Oh, duh.
That's kind of sketch.
That's really obnoxious, actually, isn't
it?
Yeah, it's real obnoxious.
cuz then it's going to be like,
wait, but it's not even
Oh, I know what's happening. That's
Yeah, it's dumb.
For the sake of having a demo, we're
going to do this jank thing real quick.
tail scale compiled game. Oh, that's
kind of cool. What are other options for
policy name? What's the best choice?
So, um, today
for ocean environments, you can see that
there are a bunch of them, but they're
not like all swappable. Like, the best
thing is if you want a custom model,
just look at the ones in this popular
lib ocean torch file and you just make
like a little policy for your N.
Typically, you just keep the LSTM. The
LSTM is pretty much always good. And
then, uh, if you need a custom encoder,
you write a custom encoder. You know, if
you have 2D data, use like a little com
stack.
And we have examples
All right, this is solid. That's our
tool tip prototype.
195 for 10 under 170 body weight
is not bad.
I was only at 210 for 10 back when I
weighed 185.
No mil val running depth 8.
Wait, Jess, don't you only need like
depth two to have something like
reasonable?
All right, I have um I think I have a
meeting to get to.
Let me see.
Yeah, I got a meeting to get to in a
couple minutes. All right, here's the
plan, guys. I've got probably two hours
worth of meetings right now. Um,
so I should be back, maybe less, right?
Let me think.
2:00 p.m. 3:00 p.m.
I should be able to get in a dinner a
pre-dinner stream probably like
somewhere between 3:30 and 4 Eastern.
I'll be back. I'll stream until 6 and
then after dinner I'll stream some more
and we'll see if we can just crush this
uh this refactor. That's going to be the
main objective today.
I got to run for this. Um, for folks
here,
all of this is open source. You can just
go to puffer.ai. You can start the
GitHub. It is free. It helps me out a
ton. Start the GitHub. Join on Discord
if you want to get involved with
development. A nice community there. And
you can follow me on X for more content,
including all the educational guides and
the research posts as well.
Thanks and I will uh see you